before I even get started if anybody's
heading downtown after the show and want
to split an uber I'm down there's
nothing to write home anybody oh man
yeah see my uh my mother made me wear
this suit so I hope you're happy now
enjoy saying I should probably tell you
guys a little bit about me that you
might not know just by looking at me I
was raised by both of my parents yeah
which was the end of my rap career
it's really hard to be a gangster rapper
when there's a positive male role model
in the home yeah I uh I grew up in
Washington DC PG County Maryland area
and it's change it's been gentrified
my friends a man like man ain't [ __ ] you
fight the whole hood they kicked us out
moved us across the street from rich
people I'm like Mike you rob people for
a living and they move you across the
street from rich people now you can just
walk to work that's the easy commute God
closes one door opens another and you go
through that door and burglarize people
I don't see the problem
I gots to meet that first ginger fire
that that Christopher Columbus of
oppression what were they thinking you
know we'll go nice between us abandoned
building in this crock house yoga studio
yeah yo go fix the schools a lot of
people are processing their
justification in DC and I'm a retired
protestor I can't do it it's hard to be
just angry every day I'm first of all
protests start way too early start like
7:30 in the morning
black lives can't matter at brunch
I was traveling down south doing comedy
performing in the deep south I forgive I
was at Mississippi Alabama I don't know
hey doll smells the same and and uh I
went to this bar like it's really
country like hillbilly kind of bar and
this is when I noticed that America had
changed because it's drunk white guy
comes up to me he's like hey man I'm so
sick of these Mexicans coming into our
country the fact that he could confide
in me a Negro his hate for other races
some you guys see it as racism I see
this progress I grew up with the twin
brother named Terence I have a twin
named Terence Oh
that's enough he's also wearing a suit
because joy saying told him to box my my
mother couldn't really explain with
twins word to us right see bees make up
something in her head she got okay baby
I'm twins are one sperm two eggs Jesus's
love a little bit of Holy Ghost power
spring at all time I believe that's what
I was 17 years old my brother had like a
attitude problem he's always getting
into stuff right you were
you were and you actually problem so a
lot of times people in my neighborhood
will go looking for my brother
and end up finding me first it's really
hard to explain to somebody that wants
to hurt you they got the wrong person
you look exactly like the person that
they want to hurt no I don't know you
man I never met you before huh I don't
know you know who's bought summer rolls
I don't even know her no no no see if
you hit me you hit me let me explain
one sperm to
[Applause]
you